hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in chapter 15 of his master work
leviathon Thomas Hobbs is going to make
a declaration about the true and only
moral philosophy now what does he mean
by that as it's going to turn out his
own moral philosophy which is being put
forth in leviathon offered to rulers as
something which they can both be guided
by and also impose upon their subjects
lacking this we're going to be stuck in
Conflict forever and we want to back up
a little bit because what is the true
and only moral philosophy concern well
what we call the laws of nature not a
completely new idea goes all the way
back possibly to Aristotle depending on
how you're reading them and definitely
to the stoics playing a major role
within medieval philosophy and then in
early modern philosophy where Hobs is
going to transform it into something
quite a bit different and so chapter 14
and 15 are going to do several things
one of them is to identify what the laws
of nature actually are there's several
at the very start that get a lot of
discussion and then he goes through the
rest of them and you know he's going to
explain each of them and why it's
actually a law of nature
so what is a law of nature well he's
going to tell us that it's a precept or
a general rule so something that's
binding on all of us which is found out
by human reason a capacity that hob says
that we all possess actually once we're
you know of age forbidding what is
destructive of one's life so if you can
avoid being in a condition of war well
then you should get out of that
condition of war because war is
destructive to your life you if we think
about the other laws of nature don't do
things that are going to make you
noxious to everybody else he's got one
where he explains it by using a metaphor
of stones that are being put together in
a wall if they don't fit into the wall
they're going to throw the stone aside
and similarly for people who don't fit
into the rest of society complacence or
getting along with other people is one
of those laws of nature but there's
others that have to do with gratitude or
with Justice or other things like that
so forbidding what is destructive of
one's life or taking away the means of
preserving one's life which often depend
on other people in society or to Adit
that is to leave out what one thinks
will best preserve one's life so you
could see these as you know overarching
norms and guidelines for how to keep
yourself alive how not to do dumb things
that will take away the means to keeping
yourself alive and to do the things that
you need to do in order to in you know
have a continued existence and we could
even go further and talk about having a
you know a decent existence but Hobbs is
mostly focused on that and then he tells
us a few other things so he's got these
Latin Expressions he says that they
oblige Us in for foro interno not in
foro external so interno is our you know
interior so the realm of our desire we
can recognize yeah I want to do these
sorts of things I want to live this sort
of way I want to be this kind of person
but that does doesn't necessarily oblige
us yet to putting these into action or
practice something else is going to be
needed and that is what he calls the
establishing of a commonwealth and a
sovereign an authority who has the power
of life and death and can compel us to
do these things so he gives an
explanation here he that should be
modest and tractable and perform all he
promises in such time and place where no
man else should do so would make himself
a prey to others and procure his own
certain ruin contrary to the ground of
all laws of nature which tend to
Nature's preservation right so uh what
we need is something that is going to
bind us in foral external and we'll get
to that in just a bit and then he tells
us one other very interesting thing
before we get to the talk about you know
this this science he tells us that the
laws of nature are IMM mutable and
internal why well what does that mean to
begin with immutable cannot be changed
Eternal apply throughout all time for
Hobs because there's no notion of
Eternity as something like transcending
time for Hobs why Injustice ingratitude
arrogance Pride iniquity exception of
persons that is giving some people
greater priority than others and the
rest can never be made lawful can never
be that war shall preserve life and
peace destroy it you might say well wait
a second if I fight against somebody
that's being in a state of war and I
could save my own life with self-defense
yes yes that that's quite true Hobs is
talking in general so all of these and
notice that he's been talking about
qualities here that are displayed in
desire and action all of these are
things that fit the bill
for you
know uh keeping us from doing what's
destructive to our life they help to
preserve the means that are needed for
life and all of that sort of thing so
he's going to go on and say the same
laws because they only oblig oblige only
to a desire and Endeavor um are easy to
be observed they require nothing but
Endeavor he that endeavor their
performance fulfills them and he that
fulfill the law is us now Endeavor means
you know to desire in this this case
right and then he goes on and here's
where we get to the the real Crux the
science of the laws of nature he says is
the true and only moral philosophy and
now he's going to explain this why is
that the case what is moral philosophy
nothing else but the science of what is
good and evil and now now we get to the
first seeming
Paradox so he goes out and
explains uh good and evil in the
conversation in society of mankind good
and evil are names that signify our
appetites and aversions which in
different tempers customs and doctrines
of men are different and diverse men
differ not only in their judgment on the
senses of what is pleasant and
unpleasant to the taste smell hearing
touch and sight but also what is
conformable or disagreeable to reason in
the actions of common life the same man
in diverse times differs from himself
and at one time Praises uh that that is
calls good another time he dis praises
and calls evil and this uh leads to
disputes controversies and at last war
right and so if our what he calls
private appetite is the measure of Good
and Evil we're always going to be in a
state of War so what the hell is the
science of you know uh good and evil
then it seems like it's the science of
something very mutable so here's hobb's
resolution to this which you may or may
not find uh particularly satisfying he
goes on and he tells us that
um uh here we go all men agree upon this
that peace is good and therefore also
the way or means of Peace which are what
the laws of nature and now he doesn't
talk about them as the laws of nature as
rules he says justice gratitude modesty
Equity mercy and then he says and the
rest of the laws of nature now if a law
is strictly speaking a rule you could
say well okay we can interpret this be
just be Equitable be grateful but he
actually calls these by their their
names so they're really not just rules
they are qualities which he's going to
call very shortly virtues which embody
those rules which are Guided by those
rules we could say and so he tells us
these are moral virtues their contrary
vices are evil and it tells us the
science of virtue and vice is moral
philosophy and therefore the true do
of the laws of nature is the true moral
philosophy so we've got an interesting
identification here we go from what
might be viewed as a
deontological but also consequentialist
approach to ethics to what we often call
virtue ethics and there's a lot of
discussion about whether Hobbs is indeed
a virtue ethicist or not most
interpreters will say well if he is he's
certainly an unusual kind of virtue
ethicist but um you notice that he is
using a lot of virtue language here and
in a very very explicit way so this is
what the um science of the laws of
nature the true moral philosophy is
actually going to be about and he's not
only going to identify the virtues and
vices he says that what is really
important is
explaining what makes them good or bad
what makes a virtue of virtue what makes
a vice a vice now he's going to not only
have done this himself in chapter 14 and
15 with each of the laws of nature which
can then be identified with a particular
virtue right and uh also identified
against a particular Vice he's also
going to criticize other approaches to
this so for example the Aristotelian
approach he says not seeing wherein
consisted their
goodness nor that they come to be
praised as the means of Peaceable
sociable and comfortable living they
place them in a mediocrity of passions a
middle state right the famous
Aristotelian mean as if not the cause
but the degree of Daring made fortitude
or not the cause but the quantity of a
gift made liberality so Hobs is directly
targeting all the Aristo out there and
anybody else influenced by Aristotle
who's saying well what we want is the
right proportion the right amount and
that the motive is not what's really
important now is that a fair
representation of Aristotelian virtue
ethics definitely not it might be uh
viewed as a fair uh assessment of the
aristotelians of his time Hobbs thinks
that it's absolutely important that we
know why something is a virtue and he's
going to can attack it to being a law of
nature being something what a reasonable
person can identify as a means for
saving their life and uh you know not
getting themselves in trouble with their
fellow citizens
right now he says one other thing here
these dictates of reason men use to call
that is they're accustomed to call by
the name of laws but improperly for they
but conclusions or theorems concerning
what condu to the conservation and
defense of themselves and this is where
we sort of foreshadow some interesting
issues that are going to arise with some
further implications so the first one is
actually in chapter
23 he tells us that those who have the
authority to teach or enable others to
teach the people their duty to The
Sovereign power and instruct them in the
knowledge of what is just and in just
right are public ministers so this has
the implication that anybody who is
teaching or assigning other people to
teach or you know charging them or
forbidding them to teach about moral
philosophy moral philosophy understood
in this proper sense is actually a
public Minister there is no merely
private teaching of what we could say uh
hsian virtue ethics consists in by
virtue of teaching about virtues and
vices you are a public Minister maybe a
good one maybe a bad one depending on
how you're doing that chapter 26 deepens
the issue in a number of ways the first
thing that we want to look at is that he
tells us that the laws of nature aren't
really laws unless we are actually in a
commonwealth so he says that the law of
Nature and the civil law contain each
other and are of equal extent the laws
of nature which consist in equity
Justice gratitude and other moral
virtues on these depending in the
condition of M nature are not property
properly laws but qualities that dispose
people to peace and to OB obedience once
a commonwealth is once settled then they
are actually laws and not before by
being the commands of the Commonwealth
therefore also civil laws it is The
Sovereign power that obliges people to
obey them and now notice what else he's
going to say in the differences of
private men to declare what is equity
what is Justice and what is moral virtue
and to make them binding this in foro
external right
there is need of the ordinances of
sovereign power and punishments to be
ordained for those who will break them
so in a certain sense this true moral
philosophy this science of the laws of
nature the science of the virtues and
vices it's not really effective unless
you've got some Sovereign power to back
it up and to enforce it uh chapter 26
also includes another interesting
discussion uh here as well the laws of
nature he tells us don't actually need
publishing or
Proclamation why is that the case he
says well they're contained in this one
sentence approved by all the world do
not to that do not that to another which
thou thinkest unreasonable to be done by
another to thyself so the you know
sometimes it's called the Golden Rule uh
often times this formulation is it's
called the silver rule because it's not
do positively to another what you would
want done onto you don't do to another
what you don't want done to you well is
hobs right about this does every single
person automatically acknowledge this
that doesn't really seem to be the case
so this would seem to weaken his own
point of view but perhaps there's a
Reconciliation that's possible then we
get yet a third in interesting
implication that Hobbs himself draws out
so he tells us that the interpretation
of the laws of nature is something that
The Sovereign or the sovereign's
ministers gets to carry out and he tells
us that it depends not on books of moral
philosophy who does he have in mind
there Aristotle Plato cisero
commentaries on that basically everybody
else other than Hobs so he says that the
authority of writers without the
authority of the Commonwealth makes not
their opinion law be they ever so true
and you might say well wait a second
Thomas Hobs wouldn't that apply to you
and Thomas Hobbs would say as a matter
of fact that actually does because in
the next line what does he say that
which I I have written in this treaties
concerning the moral virtues and of
their necessity for the procuring and
maintaining peace though it be evident
truth is not therefore presently
law but because in all commonwealths in
the world it is part of the civil law so
I have managed to articulate what the
true basis of law moral norms and civil
law ought to be and that's the reason
why my leviathon can actually be binding
on everyone he says uh for though it be
naturally reasonable It Is by The
Sovereign power that it is Law and then
he goes on and he says otherwise it's a
great error to call the laws of nature
unwritten law and therefore we see so
many volumes published and in them so
many contradictions of one another and
of themselves so all the ear
or contemporary books of moral
philosophy ah contradicting each other
contradicting themselves they're not
actually true they may contain some
truths but they also have a lot of
falsehoods in them my book is true but
it's not law until it's recognized and
instituted by some sort of civil
Authority The Sovereign who then decides
who's going to teach teach it and under
what conditions it's going to be taught
for the
interpretation of these laws so a little
bit of a paradoxicality there right if
this is all true well why isn't it
automatically binding well Hobbs has an
answer to that you know you can
recognize laws of nature moral virtues
you can talk meaningfully without
contradiction about them in a true way
but you still need some political
authority to to put them into place and
move them from the internal Forum of
desire to the external form of action or
human behavior so there really isn't a
contradiction there although it it does
seem paradoxical and Hobbs is asserting
that in kind of self-serving way perhaps
his philosophy that he's laying out for
us here in Leviathan is the true and
only
moral
philosophy